these people have no choice but to wait
for help the flood has left them with no
means of escape except pakistani army
rescuers who bring them to safety by
helicopter many here weren't as lucky
dozens in Punjab province were killed
when the roofs of their houses collapsed
for days of torrential monsoon rain have
also flooded the industrial city of raw
pindi near the capital Islamabad the
only way out for many here is by boat
many people are still stranded the flood
has caused suffering and financial
losses people's cattle have drowned
their belongings are ruined the deluge
has brought back memories of a 2010
flood that covered a fifth of the
country and water and cost 2000 Pakistan
is their lives it seems the worst is not
over yet this time either rivers
continue to rise in Punjab province
dozens have also been killed in the
disputed Kashmir region between Pakistan
and India in India authorities say it's
the worst flooding they've seen in two
decades at least 50 were killed on their
way to a wedding when their bus skidded
off a mountain road and plunged into a
river it took two days to recover all
the victims bodies